what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch the
rings of Power episode 5 today John how
are you I'm excited I can't wait how are
you doing well thank you for asking all
right quick recap episode one
meh in the middle and then episode two
liked episode three pretty boring
episode four best one so far really
enjoyed that one let's see what episode
5 has to offer us today ladies and
gentlemen leave a like also you know do
that thing where you subscribe and click
that Bell and uh full-length Reaction
watch along as we sync up with your own
copy meaning a Time code involved for
super sexy Rejects at our patreon page
and over there we cover several shows
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch alongs included lastly the
team of prepper thank you for helping us
edit down these these videos let's let's
do it let's return to Middle Earth
and at the first Bush of the oak leaves
we head to the Grove a whole Orchard
parking with with bar apples plums
apricots carts you you love it oh yeah
the farmer's market downtown it's the
only trouble is there's 100 pairs
between here and there anything else
you're good
because you're here to help I like the
switching of the POV shots on that
yeah
I trade all I've known for the unknown
ahead
call to me call to me lands far away I
like this song
that's one thing about
this universe in particular I appreciate
is that musical aspect everybody's got
songs they sing
[Music]
who are these guys
foreign
new characters yep
knock knock put the devil in
he's like the anti-nascool
how does it feel good I wish
you could feel like I do
some of the legions
it is time
Orcs can actually they eventually evolve
to be able to be in the sunlight right
Fellowship of the Ring they were in the
sun yeah yeah
I mean probably once uh once that Center
core of dark power is is really firing
we've been ordered to abandon this Tower
and swear fealty to their commander who
among you will stand and fight
um
I say be better to take our chances bow
into the supposed enemy
survive this
follow me
we will follow me to follow someone else
the most consistent thing about the
crowds in this show is they are easily
swayed with just a couple of sentences
yes
they are truly the angry mob
[Music]
of course yeah we were going west
not anymore not till I've done something
worthy of numenor but we're far more
volunteers than we could ever hope to
accommodate
slipping to the front of the line
spoiled [ __ ] I'm ready to serve
but you had your chance
and you made your choice
[ __ ] door
and where did the enemy head next
further south I should think towards the
Watchtower of ostith my thanks Lord
halbrandt I'm certain your fellowship
will prove just as invaluable once you
make landfall
ah
Oh Ellen informed us of your aspiration
to unite your people
did she know
I trust she was not speaking in haste
was a goddamn manipulator you use me I
have just convinced numenor to send five
ships and 500 men to Aid your people
and place a crown upon your head many
might assume
you used me
[Music]
power dynamics find another head to
Crown
oh God come on man keep moving
easier in the dark harford's must be
jacked
there's a lot of manual labor moving
around like I think they're kind of like
they're kind of like ants
they're sleeping like they're tidy but
they're strong yeah
and they are Builders and they migrate
and stuff they all serve a central Queen
controls them with pheromones
this is plain asleep fungus he's
responsible isn't he the big fella what
precisely do you expect me to do about
this what you ought to have done at the
camp
they're wheels and leave them
uh oh
the big guy's been doing good he's gonna
show he's doing good in this episode so
you just wait lady before you pass
judgment
you see what a tremendous asset this guy
could be
foreign please
as I was saying
oh no it's got to be like a wild boar or
something
[Music]
one of the people screaming woke culture
at this [ __ ]
here they come now
come on where's my giant where's my
Gandalf of Sauron or whatever
come on mystery Legacy character
he's good my man
not peril
[Applause]
nicely done
they're the three hyenas
scream
three of trespass
ES
to this 80s music it's raining Montage
let's see
I have to Sauron it's the fear of the
night
I will keep it strong and simple
sit back twist
oh even I could do that that's a totally
whole new style of fighting anyone that
does
I will promote
the
lieutenant
I don't know exactly know what that
position is
I'll take a rank
that's not the gut you're not going for
the gut yeah bad aim my guy kind of
looks like Dwayne Johnson with a fro
yeah this guy's gonna play a younger
Dwayne Johnson in something swordmanship
is about balance rather than strength
fight with your feet not your arms
[Music]
oh oh awesome she's like Zorro
slice one of those shirts off
whoa yeah
I go for the finger oh smart yeah they
don't have any health guards
[Music]
you're ruining this man's shop
don't plant roots
keep moving are you training or showing
off yes
I should pretty impressive choreography
[Music]
never trust brute calls to best a note
well done
left hand
way to go Dwayne well it took like 15 of
you
you should all be lieutenant
what makes you think Miriam's mind and
my own are not as well in this because
my father would seem to die than take
orders from an elf you speak boldly boy
we need more of that around here
soon we will save the little man of
Middle Earth lift them up and give them
the king they've long awaited
the king who will be forever Not Dead
you can now that might benefit us long
term my dude
don't go
to Middle Earth
all that awaits you there
death Darkness
[Music]
it's not that bad and it cuts to him
maybe he's
he's the dark
hey
no worry wow
[Music]
foreign
maybe it's in his nature I would think
our Dwarven friend far too Stout of
heart to be offended by an honest
inquiry I have an honest inquiry for you
honestly
the table
why do you ask we deserve its use
for the most sacred purposes
to our honored dead
yikes
I bought it at a flea market
please forgive our sacrilege Lord Duran
we shall have to send it home with you
so it can be treated with the proper
respect he just manipulated you to get
in that table
what kind of King are you I like Dern a
lot but I also feel like you'd be the
kind of friend where I'd be worried that
I'm doing something wrong around him all
the time yeah I do everything is an
affront to the dwarf somehow
are you familiar with the song of the
roots of the thyglier it speaks of a
battle not over honor or duty but over a
tree within which some claim was hidden
the last of the Lost tumor Hills
[Music]
on one side fought an Elven Warrior
the other a balrog of morgoth
channeled all his hatred into the tree
to destroy it
but despite our every effort
our decline has only quickened
the blight upon this tree is but an
outer manifestation of an inner reality
root rot
did the dwarves find the ore or not
I swore an oath
It Is by such things our very souls are
bound I do not intend to let mine slip
away on the basis of mere hope yes or no
it's blink or something you're only
apologizing because you think now that
I've been promoted I can get you on the
Expedition I
foreign
you're right
fine you get a free hit
Joel gut your choice one hit
three
um two
actually
oh nice damn
[Music]
what's homie hoping to find out
or is he just sabotaging this yep it's
gonna make sure that uh
the whole Fleet burns down
I eat
staring away
are you setting the ship on fire
whoa
[Music]
okay
[Music]
wow
oh you could use this as a way to get
yourself on that boat that just blew up
I tried to stop this guy he was in a
fishing boat a cost must have gone up a
cask
oh you could have just left but he saved
my life
captain
finally did you believe it oh no
validate you finally earned something a
day in your life
and now he's got a political bargaining
chip
it's Council will reconvene at first
light to make a final decision
see to it Lord halbrand attends We Know
You're Gonna Go
this is not a very
sturdy small table hiking deceived me
but now our people are doomed unless I
break an oath
and betray a friend
go talk to him again tonight your father
set sail I heard your mother pleading
with him not to go asking him imploring
him why why must it be him
and you know what he said
he wants to get away from his son
you guys are needy he's the only one who
could do it
[Music]
episode's theme satisfied dads
weiner dad
uh zilders dad El Ron's dad
Duran's dad the Elders of the Harford
tribe
essentially everyone's mom and dad
stop fighting me and together let us
fight them
you don't know what
I said before I ended up on that route
you don't know how I survived
oh he was a servant for them
who was it you lost
up into him he was killed these POV
shots man so this is about vengeance one
cannot satisfy Thirst by drinking sea
water and what is it why do you keep
fighting because I cannot stop
bloodthirst my closest friend conspired
with the King to Exile me because I
believe they could no longer distinguish
me
from the evil I was fighting
This Woman's Disturbed
you live that long
there is no peace to be found for you
here
and nor for me
no lasting peace in any path but that
which lies across the sea
I have fought for centuries seeking to
earn mine
this is how you earn yours
see that is
how you lead not drag
you got to move them with their hearts
before you move them with your vision
is that confirmation you are so wrong
you know
maybe not I'll serve you then
oh
only blood combined
well did he do it definitely definitely
killed him
this before
oh cool whoa
gnarly
our enemy knows your son has what he
needs to enact it
your son's special
yeah he's meant for big things no
for the enemy and you take away
everything
from your son his son's off to him this
conversation should be in private yeah
and when they March upon us this Tower
will fall
foreign
amount of people
I don't need that many works
you know kill like 15 people come on
it's Overkill you're much more efficient
Army you made it up didn't you
this has been wanting a new table for
years so
what'd I tell you
I did not know it
but I came for Mitra without it my kind
must either abandon these Shores by
spring or perish our Immortal selves
will
dwindle slowly diminishing
there's a tree I could show you
all we are is Dust in the Wind dude the
fate of the entire Elven race
is in your hands
whose hands
yours
thank me after we find a way to convince
my father look at me please get moving
it's a long journey back
no this sunlight is starting to give me
a sour stomach
burden halved
tell these are the tables from me I'm
pretty sure luck elf
God you freaking eavesdropping elves I
know
you're using those ears of years to
cheat I really like elrond Adorn a lot
oh yeah they're they're the heart and
soul of the show
oh no don't mislead us dude
I'll show you don't do it
I mean he does look good
now before we set out I should tell you
all what happened when uh before
collateral found me laughs
so just stop for a second please
report to the horse master
I thought I was in cavalry you are
stable sweet
[Laughter]
love you man
I go shovel some horse [ __ ]
[Music]
oh yeah that's what you live for glass
real that's what you live for battle
armor getting that armor
the wind in my back
and now she's hot isn't she I see a
silver door yeah
you got this man
I'll remove that arm residential
a big old shoulder pads elbow pads
[Music]
Zippity Doo Dah there we are Zippity a
so I'm gonna take my headphones off for
a tiny bit while you talk okay it's just
been on for a long time in my ears your
ears probably are sore it really hurts
yeah shot some stuff earlier so why
don't you go ahead and talk for a little
bit and uh you know what you think of
the episode honest thoughts all around
honest thoughts all around I thought
this was a decent episode it's not every
week I come in hoping for like a slam
dunk and uh last week is still as close
as we've gotten but uh you know I'm here
for it and uh I'm not like in love with
anything but there's a lot I really like
I I agree with what you said elrond and
Duren are are thus far clearly Far and
Away the heart and soul of the show and
I loved their moments I feel like even
in little brief moments those two
managed to ring a lot of richness and a
lot of life
out of the circumstances both big and
small and that helps to really ground
things in a sense of
I don't know I I feel like when you get
too far into just the desperation and
just the burden of purpose you can lose
the idea that what we're really fighting
for is
is these little you know human homey
things you know is our bonds and our you
know uh good-natured ribbing back and
forth and you know visiting a friend
after a long time and you know uh uh
rejoicing in each other's Prosperity you
know all those things and those things
are alive within those characters and I
feel like the rest of the time like I
said the the world maintain remains
beautifully realized the cast remains uh
I think well chosen I I like everybody
um but yeah they they are Far and Away
the most alive thing about the show to
me and then and then certain characters
get uh you know moments to be like that
but it's this episode kind of called my
attention toward like the way they
proportion everything out because
I I I'm curious
as to what like the I imagine most
writers rooms like this have to have a
big board with a lot of cards on it and
uh you know you got your your five
season Arc probably vaguely sketched out
and then you've got your first season
all broken down and I'm like what were
the proportions for where they decided
to place all these different stories
because you know like we get the hard
foots back in this episode and and a
couple things happen with them but it
kind of felt like they they went oh yeah
yeah they weren't here last week so we
gotta check in on them really quick all
right so now let's move on and uh you
know you've got a whole bunch of other
trouble a brewing in most every other
pocket of the episodes uh so
uh but you're back with the headphones
on so I don't want to I don't want to
take the whole the whole thing before
you've had it go ahead You're Gonna Roll
go for it uh but yeah I don't know like
I
I like seeing things with Adar and
wondering if he's Sauron and
I don't know it's it's everything it's
weird a part of me wishes I like
everywhere we cut to and I I like again
all the actors that populated in the
world itself but sometimes I feel like
if we could really
treat each of these settings I don't
know what what the solution would be but
basically treat each of these settings
kind of like they do with elrond in
Turin because with them too we get
personal moments and circumstances but
we also get the big picture stuff and I
feel like with most of the other plot
lines like with Bronwyn and
um Aaron dear I feel like that is a lot
of the big Strokes you know we see to
get another you know rousing speech and
then you get that people dividing into
half
and it's like that moment where they go
and swear fealty to Adar to Sauron or
whoever you are I don't care I'm loyal
to you like that was interesting but I
feel like that moment could have had
that that sequence could have felt more
like a whole part of the episode rather
than just one of many scenes
and one of many moments that seems like
it's gonna amount to some kind of big
punch and then it and then it just
transitions into their marching and oh
there's a whole lot of them and that's
kind of a scary image
um and and you know you've got
everything going on in numenor which is
not like I I appreciate the arguments
back and forth and the debate but it is
falling into that hole for me with a lot
of these plot lines where it's like okay
I get it you know our uh gladriel is is
She's suffering this great loss and she
can't let go of her fight and she needs
to you know Rouse everybody to her cause
but
I feel like in some of those intimate
moments they they could make up so much
ground by doing a little bit of personal
character work instead of just
checking back in with the core wound and
then you know
I don't know I feel like some of these
debates should be a little more rich and
a little more uh hard one because I feel
like then they would feel more cathartic
but uh what do you think gee I thought
it was the best episode we've gotten so
far really no no
I was like oh I'm ready for a surprise
uh no I I uh I agree I mean I thought
the episode was fine
um I don't have a
uh disdain for it wasn't like that's I
wasn't bored uh no I'm not exactly
thrilled or excited during it yeah it
was like it's fine I I still feel like
we're five episodes in and how many
episodes are do do we have confirmation
it's an eight episode it's Eight
Episodes I feel like by now we should be
in much more compelling territory and
maybe you are uh and we just aren't I I
think what dawned on me because yeah you
bring up good points and there are two
things that I thought of in terms of the
writers
with this I'm like I imagine there's a
very great outline they have for this
and and I think what happened what what
kind of holds this show back in certain
episodes
is there's a lack of of um compelling
qualities and the actual immediate
execution of these scenes I'm like on
paper this seems like the right scene to
do this seems like the right step like
yes okay you've convinced the queen now
we gotta convince the people
um and the people are they going to be
on board and there's a little bit of
political upheavals you got to go
through as well with certain people on
the council and what does this all mean
so I I think like yeah okay so we got to
have a debate about it now the thing
that's happening is like you you said
that you thought like some of those more
personal stuff and everything being just
debated about could be more rich and I
agree that part of it is not exactly
Rich to me it seems very
kind of I don't want to say perfunctory
it's like you can see to me the
direction of it was just so obvious of
everything that was about was like okay
we know where we're gonna like by the
end of the episode they're all gonna set
sail so like yeah and and it didn't like
we need to throw a couple of things in
there and then there's some of the
things about looming threats
they feel so generic it's usually just
there's a Darkness
there's Darkness coming
and and I felt like the thing that's
really missing for this particular
series
when you are having these moments that
are supposed to feel like Monumental and
sweeping and epically heroic on on
Journeys that they're going to be
setting forth the thing that kind of
Misses for me on these episodes is
really the feeling of
there's some dark [ __ ] ahead though
there's some like terrible [ __ ] ahead or
like even I've heard theories about the
um bran we never brought about the
Bronwyn character
that and this is just a theory like in
my theory I I mean I've seen like you
know this circle in the question mark
of uh that he might be the remember when
um aoin and Return of the King cuts off
that guy's head I I I'm no man that
scene I am no man yeah and like that
might be him
uh like I've heard a theory about that
and it's not confirmed I haven't seen
think pieces wait you mean halbron
which one's a brown one she's the mom of
the year right Brown wins the public
yeah what it was like I don't know I'm
not the king yeah yeah uh Holborn yeah
the guy with the men people who
apparently did some shady stuff terrible
stuff yeah well they succumbed to Sauron
um or whatever they thought was sorry
so they
uh with hob run so halbrun Hall Brad
yeah Brad God damn it I'll run
like if he's just destined to be an
Aragorn path yeah like okay it's cliche
and if there was some type of hint kind
of what they're applying with with this
storyline that should be more
interesting but it's just not quite as
interesting as you're hoping it with the
the giant guy among the hard foots yeah
of like he's got good or bad like which
direction is this going with him like
that is kind of it's weird because for
for him they are doing the thing that
I'm like that is unknown if he's going
to be good or bad yet I'm not as
interested in it as I'd like to be and
it's one of the richest prospects
because you're like oh a character who's
being nurtured by someone who's going to
bleed them along the path of goodness
but what if they're just that's just in
their blood this is the darkness yeah
right so you have that character who who
has that quality yet it's not that
interesting and as interesting as I hope
to be and personally obviously it's all
personal all subjective
whereas with
um like any of our main players setting
sales it's like I wanna other than just
we're gonna go into battle you know like
it's the only this only dark thread is
is the obvious but it's like what what
can make it really compelling is what
will become of these people you know
that's the fear and you mean take like
Lord of the Rings it's just one example
you can pull from is what will become a
Frodo you know is he going to it's a
test of like will he descend to the
darkness will he give in to the ring
and here it is and I think they're
trying to plant some of those seeds sort
of like I don't really know other than
there's the only threat is like they
might die uh in battle you know but I
think the real thing that makes things
feel more personal
is what will become of these people and
is there a threat there of what might be
coming then like we know because of who
Galadriel is that eventually she'll
become like oh my God she's not as a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and angsty of an elf you
know she's going to become even more
wise down the line yeah being clever no
you know L Rhonda to become like oh
during the Hugo weaving apparently
you can't see it who's the more accurate
interpretation yeah stoic as hell Ron or
I'll remember the personality like which
one's the more accurate one it cracks a
smile once in a while to the hobbits you
know that freaking those I've been in
Lord of the Rings movies he's he's just
like he's agent Smith yeah um uh so I
I think that's like the main missing
quality for me whereas I kind of get
some of that with elrond and Duren of
what I'm talking about of what will
become of them what will become of their
friendship like that's such murky
territory like obviously the Me Thrill
Is Such like we we have an awareness of
what becomes a me throw but What Becomes
of them as as friends what's going to
happen to their relationship how
how murky and and and and and soiled
will the Friendship become because you
got the dad of Duran who's like
no don't be this is our greatest
secret talk and restoration and then uh
and then King elf has like doesn't seem
to have any real respect for the dwarves
but just wants something from them and
in order so they can live and then
that's gonna that can get very ugly and
so that's the part of it that makes it
really compelling to me when it comes to
the me thrill is ah [ __ ] this could land
into like what's gonna happen with the
Elves and the dwarves and what will
happen with Duran and and and and and
l-run like I'm that that's what I mean
by it's not about or they're gonna fight
in a battle together it's it's like
what's going to become of them well
that's the most interesting to me that
was the most interesting thing of the
episode because it makes the best
combination of the the macro Stakes of
this could be the end of the elves and
then the micro personal Stakes of I made
this oath I'm taking this seriously and
also I don't necessarily trust everyone
who's advising me and that makes a real
relatable and also very just palpable
situation between them and it makes a
lot of room for tension and release and
I think with those characters they also
understand the value of release because
through the Lord of the Rings trilogy
and and beyond their you know we start
to kind of fall off and take the wrong
lessons but through that trilogy I feel
like you frequently have these sweeping
epic you know grandiose and you know
very gravitational moments these these
gravitas heavy moments but you also have
always some level of brevity and and a
very Personal Touch in between those
things like no matter what a huge battle
is you know when characters are prepping
for a huge battle you'll oftentimes get
like a little aside moment of humor or
something a little more real to to
remind you and I feel like that's again
yeah them talking about that whole
dilemma is the one place where both of
those Stakes feel present together at
the same time yeah yeah I I think this
was so much of this is kind of lacking
in is truly getting a little bit more in
your show and you know you should get a
little bit more personal from time to
time
uh and I feel like they're attempting it
though that that's the thing of why I'm
not I'm not saying they're not doing it
I think there's a they're definitely
trying it it just doesn't feel like the
execution of it is hitting home
and again all subjective opinions here
just for myself it doesn't feel like
it's quite hitting the mark that it that
it sets out to hit with it with having
more of a personal effect because you
kind of see it all over this episode
like we didn't really land anywhere
different than we did last episode
yeah like we they've they agreed last
episode and now they're leaving in terms
of like the main big plot and of course
you have I I forget the name of the camp
with that Aaron deer is watching over
yeah I I forget what they are called
because some parts of this episode felt
edited funny like there were it moved
slow
but like fast at the same time like you
were just like things would just skip
ahead in time or you'd start in the
middle of something where I'm like kind
of like a little bit of a pre like a
lead into this moment a little bit more
kind of like the like door Duran sitting
at the table with the elves or like the
way how some shifts and choices happen
like with with um Bronwyn and and like
oh hey we all got to stick together and
then the next scene oh [ __ ]
everything everything sucks we're losing
and now let's look at the tower and cut
away and I understand some plot stuff
happened in between like half the people
leaving so that can make you sad or
you're worried about your son like I I
understand that like that's but that's
what I mean by the editing of It kind of
just
sometimes cut off some things that I
think could have just made some things
breathe better so it had this weird mix
of this is a slow episode but it's also
kind of a jarringly fast episode at
times where I'm like I that that
richness that you kind of crave for just
a little bit more ingredients is being
left off the plate I still gotta speed
this up a little bit I feel like maybe
the key and not to slight the hard foots
in particular I feel like maybe the key
would just be to leave one of the places
plot lines Etc leave one of the threads
mostly out each episode to give us time
to maybe miss it and B to give a little
more time to the a bunch of other things
we're focusing on because in a way those
editing Nicks and the more surface level
qualities of some of the arguments they
make the map feel smaller and it works
against how beautifully produced
everything is because it feels like okay
we're gonna cut back to New Norman and
we're gonna come back to here and we
gotta come back to here we're going to
have all these these yeah conversations
to get the plot this was the most I felt
like okay we gotta get the plot going
places like the guy blowing up the ship
I was like there are aspects of this
that could be interesting and I get that
not all the people are on board but it
feels like everybody's on board and now
the ship is blowing up and that's our
device to get a sale door onto the the
you know into this part of the story
this is the solution a little more I do
like him he's I didn't really give two
shits about him in any of the other
episodes and this is the first time like
but by the time he like hugged his
friends at the end and like sweep the
Dead sweep the horseshit like that was I
was like all right you know I think I'm
uh well I'm getting on board for this
guy yeah they made him work for it and I
think that works for the episode still
very like the most repetitive [ __ ] about
this kid it was like same thing with
like Galadriel very repetitive types of
yeah types of dialogue uh and I for them
and I feel like it works against her as
an actress sometimes and it was like in
that moment I kept I just keep wanting
them to go a little further with
everything and to maybe I I wonder if
too there's some kind of beholdeness to
the like I'm sure there is to some
degree it'd be holding quality to the
language and to the perceived demeanor
of these stories but they would maybe
give more a little more voice to each
character because I I remembered I like
her performances a lot when she's
talking to Hall brand and he's
confronting her and then they're trying
to convince each other uh of you know
she turns away as she's touching back on
that core wound of her brother and stuff
and you see like her eyes start to tear
up and in that moment I was like oh this
is a this is drawing me in I'm more than
interested now I'm actually being drawn
in and I'm actually being compelled and
uh and it's good they did that but I
feel like especially with her as a
character like in this episode you
mostly just have to watch her
maneuvering people into getting on board
with her again and it seemed kind of
barely opening her mouth wide eye
delivery again yeah and it takes actors
who I feel like it is a pitfall that I
found throughout the Hobbit movies and I
do find is kind of ailing this is you
can't be too stoic and too I know the
elves are are they age way different
than everybody in their perspective is
totally different because of that but I
think there's still a way as we saw in
The Lord of the Rings movies everyone
loved friggin Legolas and he was still
kind of laconic and mysterious in ways
but you still got that character oomph
and I feel like here I'll be honest if
Lego this was the lead I would be kind
of bored
oh sure yeah sure yeah yeah you don't
and you have to also you know in this
position he plays yeah yeah and that's
why getting more Legoland you know
Hobbit movies isn't necessarily a good
thing uh but yeah I don't I even still
though I feel like they he's got at
least the the fun back and forth with
gimlet like if they give her something
to temper again it was like Thor and
Oakenshield in those movies is kind of
reminding me of what they're doing here
it's like most all of what we check in
with you about is kind of the same you
know Stern resolve and I'm not wavering
in my mission and and you know I just
have to fight like even the conversation
the debate wasn't that interesting in
the writing because it was just like why
fight I have to fight okay fine you have
to fight well I think with everyone
whatever emotional point they have put
every one of these characters
I feel like everyone just kind of stayed
and you a very neutral spot of wherever
that emotion lies basically like
Galadriel is supposed to be the hard ass
aggressive difficult to communicate with
character and it's always kind of stayed
a little bit in the same realm yeah
of that trait yeah when uh when part of
me is like make her more of a [ __ ] like
just go out there and just make her be
like God damn you are unreasonable woman
like go out there and and push it like
push push that aggression then like push
it further like you got some shades of
of make us really question if she's
going too far yeah like show that okay
yeah this this thing's really gotten the
best version you get why some people
like why why her people committed Mutiny
on her yeah because the way she is is
just awful but then you know you gotta
balance it out with like having certain
moments where you see that she actually
is a good person but it pushed some of
those qualities you know and again like
the ones who I think they just nail it
with are during and I'll run like
they're the only ones who I'm like they
don't feel neutral to me ever a seal
door feels very much the same [ __ ] uh
the the hard foots feel that way and you
know other than like Nori being like Oh
my God he almost hurt me
[Music]
like there's
it's in in some of the so some of it
starts to feel like it's not it's
hitting kind of flat uh like Aaron dear
and Bronwyn
like man I wasn't really that was
something I was craving like I like the
choice they're making again outline
interesting outline but there's
something about the details that feels
like it's lacking and I and I can't even
I've lost more words to put my finger on
what it is that it's doing it could be
where you're saying too many plot lines
like early days of Walking Dead and
apparently later days of walking dead
but not that quite middle part
did a great job at doing that or you're
like you don't see your main characters
for like a few episodes you know some of
the best some of the best animes I've
ever like Naruto does an amazing job at
like you're only gonna focus on these
few characters for a few episodes and
you're not really gonna check in with
these other people so sometimes they're
the the affect of it because it is kind
of weird like what you said with the
hard foots of all last episode of the
room for like 10 minutes here and spread
it over the course of five different
it's pretty isolated effect so it's hard
to be affected by what just happened
when I'm like you barely check in with
them so I don't really give a [ __ ]
because we haven't really had time to
breathe with these guys it's since we
last saw them two episodes ago and and
that part is what is uh that's what I
mean by some of the the way they edit it
I think it honestly some of these issues
might come down to a a they don't have
time to truly dive into the the debates
the conversations make the dialogue more
enriching because they do have so many
characters they're cutting around too
like they just introduce some other
people on this episode I just remembered
right now who's standing over the
freaking spot where a giant guy landed
and I'm like
androgyn m is here yeah like what are
what are these things so yeah I have
I I like I didn't I really didn't hate
uh what we saw and it was like there
were Parts I enjoyed and but I I am wait
I am one of my my hope the thing I'm
holding out hope for is that because it
seems like they really had to because
they've done they mapped out like
several seasons so maybe they got
carried away too much in their outline
that they you sometimes forget that you
gotta make that each episode really
goddamn compelling instead of waiting
for the end result for everything to
click so what I'm hoping for is that by
the time you get to the final episode it
suddenly makes all these episodes feel
better yeah that's my hope I'm not
confident like I'm not I have my doubts
I'm not fully sold that by the time we
get there we'll feel that way
I'm waiting to see like okay what
happens when we get these big action set
pieces that they've been teasing for so
long now like what's gonna happen when
we get there and and the conflicts are
much more fully formed because
everyone's just kind of gearing up and
hearing whispers and blah blah
yeah because I I don't I I really
personally don't give a [ __ ] about what
happens to new Menorah like not that
what do I mean by that
I guess what I mean by that is I don't
know the people in the minor and I don't
care yeah I guess I mean I guess I mean
what I said like I I you're like oh
these people are Newman or they like
when the Silver's dad is talking with a
silver yeah they've [ __ ] did you know
they they earned the response here and
stuff yeah you know what I don't I don't
care I don't I don't know who these
people are I I can I I don't know and
all I've witnessed them do is be a mob
and and yeah either be very adverse
cereal or just hop on board for stuff
yeah so I have no sense of the community
or or even much about the queen other
than she's had to make some decisions LM
deal is the only character in numenor
who actually has the full heart and soul
right now
yeah like whenever he shows up I'm like
I care about Newman or because of you
but I think it's because he the actor
brings it the actor has that great like
British play yet modern quality like
you're the kind of actor who could be in
a modern day movie or or period piece
and you could be either super stoic or
or like someone's Uncle I'm sure yeah I
think he brings it yeah it's like you
got plot lines like freaking sodor's
sister I'm like well you're not even a
real character why is why are we giving
any attention to this right now like I
it felt like attacked on conflict that
was like last week they were they were
at least you know I don't know I didn't
feel this coming on last week and then
this week I was like oh okay I guess we
have to have some kind of other family
conflict that we're not gonna pay that
much attention to
yeah I think there is a it is bogged
down by by two it is the thing that I
think a lot of people had to worry about
is that there are
too many character syndrome uh just
because even from a writing standpoint I
I think even from a writing standpoint
it's it's hard for you to
be like oh yeah let me just get fully
invested in like the characters moments
right now and yeah because you're
hopping around history in our freaking
war and and all this other [ __ ] to live
up to because you got yeah you gotta do
World building and then and then talk
Exposition necessary Exposition
um but the only thing I think they've
really got a good grasp like a solid
grasp on is L Ron and Duran that is the
main thing that I'm like you keep the
plot moving and you keep it character
driven and it's the only time I I feel
like you're you're hitting all cylinders
with with those two
so yeah whereas the other ones really
sway for me this show
I would say
a lot of things maybe even most things
to me are interesting occasionally
things are very engrossing and
occasionally there are things that that
don't move me in one way or the other
and I hope my hope is that they will
hear some of these criticisms and then
for season two you know everyone has
been up in arms about which rights they
have and how much of just a fan fiction
is this and and to me now I almost feel
like go even further into fanfiction
like keep the important continuity
points you need to keep while we figure
out how canonical this will be regarded
in the future but like go even further
don't worry as much about being
respectful because this is just me
projecting I don't know but I almost
wonder like maybe they're trying to be a
little too respectful to the stoicism
into a certain type of language not just
go in give it like yeah really go in on
characters take some swings take some
chances you might upset more people but
you might also gain more people to what
you're doing that's interesting in this
room this has to be a exciting yeah this
has to be exciting and emotionally
gripping and and for some I see on
social media for some it does hit those
marks and that's great for you I don't
think this is a majority consensus that
like
like most people I like I don't feel
like we have a minority opinion no and
nor do I share that other opinion about
anything with a woman being woke like I
don't I don't share that side
um but I think in terms of the
storytelling is and how that's being
displayed I don't feel like we have
necessarily an unpopular opinion about
stuff uh I I I but I do want to
acknowledge that there is a complete
opposite side where people really are in
love with this show and that's great
that's that's really that's really great
to have that
you're gonna see something like this
though and I'm like did this these last
two episodes really need to be like 60
million dollars
and then you forget you start to forget
about those high production values in
the wake of things like that and they
can sometimes work work against I mean
that's the thing is is I think you know
the filmmaking barring some Pace issues
some of the times is usually pretty epic
pretty world class and I can see some
people really latching on to it from
that perspective you know what a lot of
this feels like lately in this show to
me it feels like the first half of the
two of The Two Towers where it's just
like a slow dark slow dark drama without
any of the really compelling darkness
that that movie had it's just
like a drama like a a well because
you're watching so many people be tested
and I think that those movie not to
always harp this but I think those
movies had a better grip on even Your
Heroes even your Cipher characters have
conflict and deteriorate and really have
to go through the hard battle of
choosing to do good and do the right
thing and follow the mission and people
get corrupted and people experience
remorse whereas I feel like here you
have characters who are presented nobly
maybe misunderstood from the outside but
from your narrative perspective or
you're never given reason to suspect
they might waver you just know to trust
their judgment because they you know are
these archetypical characters and you
know I again I feel like that gray not
everything needs to be anti-heroes and
and you know like really grungy gray
areas but I think that harshness of the
entire undertaking needs to be applied
to the beauty of everything and I've
feel like we only check in with that
harshness when we you know go check in
with the Orcs And yeah I think you check
in with the darkness one that's like
this is a dark scene because there's
violence there's a shadow and we got
either Wards or Orcs or something yeah
like it's a physically Darkness yeah
well that's the thing is I feel like the
most effective elements I feel like
maybe you know like
sometimes the physical elements are what
what uh sweep people up the most I feel
like that's probably where I would
imagine that's that's what works for the
people it works for the most yeah I
think I just need everything to kind of
I don't know what you're saying I feel
like I I I'm getting this this this
craving for things just to hit harder of
okay uh iron deer and and uh got brownie
um Bronwyn
uh I wanna feel the the Desolation and
and the fear I want to fear I want to
feel the fear of what they're dealing
with I want to feel the desperate the
desperation of what they're stacked up
against I want to feel that with the
people the numenor the the again those
same emotions of like I wanna feel why
they're going to war why they have to
fight what they're afraid of instead of
just laying out like facts about things
and you know oh my God yeah why are
these people fighting to protect and to
Vanquish I wanna I want that like why we
must rise up why we must band together
what will happen if we don't and you
know as opposed to just like people
talking counsel all the time yeah you
know we we need that punch and and we're
not quite there and we're five episodes
in and I'm just like everything's just
been fine
it's always about to take off except for
episode four which felt like it was
actually taking off you know like even
in the two towers when
uh the people of Rohan uh fought it like
joined the battle Yeah in the end of the
movie
I'm like we've only met them in this
movie you know but when they joined
you're like [ __ ] yeah yeah the debate is
really palpable and and you see where
everyone's coming from even if you agree
with certain people more than others and
then you get that huge catharsis when
they actually do make the choice you can
feel what it is of why they were afraid
to join the fight and then now they're
in the fight there's like this elf who
dies in The Two Towers in this like
really slow way and I'm like I don't
even know who this elf is but when those
but when those elves show up in that
fight you're like they joined the fight
they didn't think it'd be happening but
here they are you know my man let's do
it because you're so unwrapped in like
oh God
only have to lead these people into a
fight that seems like there's no no real
odds in their favor yeah it convinces
you that this is all we have and we just
gotta work with it rather than leaving
you to go no they'll show up yeah figure
out how it's gonna happen I guess that's
what we need is like we need to feel how
the we really need to feel the odds
stacked against them and we need to feel
how just horrendous and and desperate
everyone is and it's and maybe it'll get
there but right now it just feels like
like Talking Heads about politics
like even even for a seal door I'm like
what the it's hard for me to get him
like I like him he's like passively
likable and he but there's like no real
emotion for me of like why do you I'm
kind of with his dad like what's her
deal
why do you want to see really you seem
like you're just trying to make a name
for yourself because you want to make a
name for yourself as opposed to you're
trying you're fighting for something you
believe in that that you need to be a
part of or else you're going to regret
not having been a part of this fight for
your people like that's not the
impression I get yeah I was with his
friends when he goes to ask him to his
buddy to sneak him on the guys
I want a good reputation I want to look
good like this time I'll I'll get with
it this time I promise that's what it
seems it it doesn't feel like there's
something truly inspiring a real
character change overcoming odds with
anyone here and it's it's bumming me out
yeah like that's the basis of your big
war fantasy idea is is just what are the
odds you gotta overcome and then you
arouse people up and you get together
and here we are let's let's kick some
ass like that's about as simple as it
gets
yeah well I don't know the the way
they've drawn the seal doors so far if
he just kind of feels a bit like a like
a flippant character like uh well I I
guess I screwed up well what's my next
opportunity joining this uh Royal Guard
thing all right I guess I'll volunteer
for that yeah like this is our chance to
meet isildur and a steel door was more
interesting in the movies as a man
of like the man who who could have been
the Savior yeah and like oh what was he
and then he gave into the ring it felt
like that the three minutes of screen
time that man has signed now is way more
intriguing than anything we've got to
know we should at least yes see the
seeds of his ambition and the seeds of
his benevolence like we should at least
see a little bit of of each of those and
right now we see basic like a bit of you
see it doesn't seem like a bad guy so
that's benevolence enough I guess but I
feel like he got like spoil the Latin
yeah
who's still doing Aladdin [ __ ] but he
doesn't have to be yeah he's got all the
means necessary to not be doing like
he's not connected with the people he
seems to try to like you know
um
um nepotism his way through life
yeah uh there's there's there's there's
things about him it's like come on show
you're I feel like you
I feel like episode two set us up to get
everything I'm kind of craving and then
we just even episode four even though I
thought that was technically the best
one we've gotten so far didn't even do
has any didn't even deliver on what I'm
talking about episode two really set us
started setting us up for that of of
those qualities to start getting that
and it still hasn't quite got there and
if we can just get there I'd be a happy
camper just that emotion I'm just
talking about the emotion if you can
just get us to the emotion
then you're set like anything else is
like whatever you know like you can
argue Logistics over this fictional
world you want but if you can just get
the emotion
Al engaging show yeah and you'll shut a
lot of people up yeah emotions
everything yeah emotion is literally
everything yeah and and you're just not
quite there and I and I think you can
even do that with stoic characters
absolutely stoic people you can totally
pull that off you know Ryan Gosling
stoked his way through something else
getting the right Gosling elf
yeah I know you absolutely can like it's
just about making the shades more subtle
but
you gotta put you gotta put that stuff
on the page or let your actors improv it
you know to some degree because a lot of
the dialogue does feel more at least in
this episode felt more like beats turned
into debates they felt like debates uh
rather than real conversations and real
convictions colliding you know you know
and yeah if we have stuff to praise if
you've actually stuck around with our
little weird Journey with the show we
will praise the [ __ ] out of things to
praise and when it works and it's
working for us we I feel like we're both
pretty Overjoyed to say yeah you know
this has been I mean I am fascinated
this is fun to me if only for the fact
that I haven't had this experience with
the show in a while especially like here
in this environment where we're like man
this is a really like strange up and
down journey I think next episode has to
kick ass it has I I think episode six
has to be the asking like I really think
that the story of this show to me is
just constantly being painted into a
corner of like you gotta bring greatness
now and I think your last three have to
hit home otherwise like who's gonna I
mean
you got to start winning over some
people you gotta start winning over some
people like frankly here's the thing is
you know if I I do question like if we
weren't covering this for the channel
would I have really continued with this
show or what I've been like ah didn't
get around to it I fell off you know but
because we cover for the channel like
there's a consistency with having to
view it and I do wonder if if like I was
just on my own if I would have just
dropped the show you know out of like
others other things to watch that are
more interesting so sure well and and as
it builds up it's it's got a yeah like
it doesn't even
have very much of a form once you get
distance from it because usually I mean
you know with a binge I'll lose you know
certain episodes of the line obviously
but with these ones that are very much
separated off like even then it still
feels just kind of like a jumble of yeah
jumble of scenes but anyway guys that's
it for today uh thanks for sticking
around for his long-ass discussion if
you had a couple or Ted Talk and uh
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
we will chat with you all soon thank you
what'd you think of the episode yeah
that question too
foreign